you posted this it looks like you're
really getting into fashion
while you're in quarantine uh
i guess it's just i like in
november when i fell till about like now
i truly just looked like
trash so i was like let's dress up
and that's from uh fashion brand company
this dress i'm wearing is also from
fashion brand company
and i came downstairs and the nice man
who lives with me was like nicole
you look like paddington 2 goes to jail
i've never seen paddington too
but i went on the internet i googled and
i looked just like paddington 2 goes to
jail
i see it right here
that's not just sort of like it's a
direct ripoff
of paddington too i found it i was like
oh man this is a real treat
it's so funny to me have you watched
paddington 2
by the way no i haven't seen it yet but
i think i'm gonna watch it people say
it's very good
let me tell you something this is a
complete side note someone explained to
me whose opinion i really respect that
it's the perfect movie
in every respect and i thought that
can't be true
and i watched it and it is
i'm not kidding it is the perfect
movie on every level
i've also been told paddington 2 is
better than paddington uno
yeah no it's like uh godfather two
godfather one
the only other film to achieve that
status paddington who'da thought